this is Sal and I'm still at Stanford
Medical School with dr. Connolly hey Sal
we're going to continue going you're
gonna have to get one unit of credit for
today Oh excellent my mother would be
proud so what we're going to look at
today is a colon polyp we had said
before polyp is something that's gonna
stick up like this so that in that last
video what we saw it wasn't it was not a
polyp that was like an irritant and
irritated part of the yeah it was it was
very it was very low-lying it was um let
me get a pen here we go so the it was
really just kind of a patch of irritant
right there I see so we've got a bigger
piece now I see that's why I just looks
okay everything else worsen so you can
see the glands look tiny in here but
roughly that last slide how big would it
be on this thing it would be about a
piece like that
I'm done to be fair it probably what was
that was what was underlying this area
right here I see I see
and then it grew on to be on something
more than that it wasn't this exact one
no it was it would grow on to be
something like it could broaden so this
is something where when we have a colon
resection if there's a cancer often
there's a polyp or are there an area of
that patch like right hyper but not
necessarily the cancer is it's in that
same section of : yeah we find that
people if they have a colon cancer often
they have lots of other pre-cancers I
see those right just through their
bowels is going through a lot like a lot
of promise some of its familial
susceptibility but a lot of it is that
they are showing a propensity to this
Isis I don't know if it's from
environmental exposures or what I see
I just just to remind myself on what
we're doing here so you cut out a bit of
: that's kind of you can just kind of
viewed as a tube because there were some
cancer there right and then this thing
might be some other polyp that's sitting
in that same section that you cut out
yeah maybe that first that second slide
we saw over the irritation that could be
like right there I see as a matter of
fact it's important on that you normally
wouldn't see this slide in a patient
because almost all polyps on the
colonoscopy is coming in and they remove
it I see through the colonoscope I see
because they don't know whether cancer
sir I don't know it's not they'll remove
it but you wouldn't see the full wall so
right out here I mean that's all the way
through the wall in which you've got
muscle
here that's much good part of the wall
and so this is the you know really kind
of going down to a full piece of the
wall I see
Wow so so this is a larger piece and
this is in order to show the polyp in
its natural environment
so um so we're going to do is were going
to begin looking at the the polyp here
and so we will first start way out here
which is to go back again to the the
normal architecture right right so we
had said they're supposed to be tubes
luckily this one it's cut right down the
middle of the tube so you can see how
big the hole is right and so yeah this
is normal architecture there and then if
I just go out a little bit and I'm just
going to come along you can see that you
have an area here which there's a bit of
irritation so it's a throne up a little
bit like we saw before but the real
trouble is this thing sticking out right
and we wonder what is that thing
sticking out and so for the medical
students we try to tell them to think
like the way the pathologist would be
that you first need to look at the
overall architecture right this is an
abnormal architecture I don't usually
stop sticking out then the next thing
you're going to do in 3d would look like
a mushroom um yeah okay so look like a
mushroom actually they tend to have
foldings on the top of them so a little
more like cauliflower oh I see is it
going to be cauliflower classy so then
when you look here at color ^ yeah they
don't have much color to them in fact
the the colonoscopy when they look at
Apollo I can kind of tell if there's a
chance of cancer because they begin
having weird blood vessels I see and
just to be clear so that they're not
this purplish color that worse you know
this is a little color added then
section and we had to put this it would
be colorless otherwise so we had to put
a stain right right around they see them
so now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
draw the area we're gonna do a
comparison see this thingamabob here
yeah oh you're gonna look at that so now
miracles of science yeah it's a
cardiology so I'm so these are cells
which are relatively normal these are
cells which are abnormal and when we
look at them a pathologist immediately
says these look angry they do they don't
look at I would say that too and so when
you look so what's angry about it as
first of all they're not committed to
being
to behaving proper behavior over here
nuclei belong at the bottom right the
things that you're supposed to do for
your job Jo B where are at the top yes
and so when you look at these guys it's
like where's your job yes and so a few
of them are making mucin but these ones
have nuclei of different sizes and
shapes yeah and they're all just they're
just doing their and they're not even
doing muse in there no some make museum
a lot of all they're doing is growing
right and so usually there's a playoff
between that if you're committed to your
specific job for writing we call it
differentiation right if you're
committed to your differentiation you
tend not to have as much propensity to
grow yeah and if you tend to grow a lot
yes and not to do the differentiation
and so this is largely that you have
this sort of chaos of nuclei less
commitment to the normal structures
right and you're not producing as much
and so what this is is this is now
called dysplasia dysplasia dys alright
later than the wrong so yes the wrong
right right and so that's what we're
just saying is we don't like the looks
of these ones and so these individual
cells look dysplastic and they grow so
then to tell whether it's cancer cancer
means in this organ that you've grown
across this line in the sand so let me
clean so literally so if you've crossed
this boundary right over here cancer
right so you so even if I'm in the polyp
up here and I'm controlling
uncontrollably you know cancer cells and
it's mutated and it's not killing itself
with what right supposed to you still
would not call it so actually cancer no
so what happens is that there's a middle
term right where it's a cancer in the
still in the usual place right and
that's carcinoma in situ did you see
okay so carcinoma in situ means it's not
an invasive cancer and therefore most
people would not really call it a cancer
it's just so wild looking up here right
you know that it would do that if it has
given any chance or time I see so what
we're saying is if something was out
here a carcinoma in in situ
yep yeah that eventually probably would
make its way yeah it just looks so keep
committed to growth and so aggressive
and right so
little differentiation but you know if
you gave a time you'd worry that it make
sense so with here though this is
dysplasia where it's it's very upsetting
that it's growing so fast what's
important about this right is in
hyperplasia right if you took away the
stimulus or irritant right you would go
back to normal
yes this will not IC like we said like
this are some irritants in the last
video is like a week later we had a
couple weeks later that that hyper
pleasure would go away right this
pleasure is here to stay that's right
this is and so the key word we use is
autonomous automatons independent it's
just whatever so it will grow no matter
what it doesn't care about clues from
neighboring cells right doesn't need
something driving it so what you have
then is this is growing right and if
it's growing and it's all by itself and
growing its then called a neoplasia your
last fascia right so neoplasia showing
displays so yeah so dysplasia just is
more of when you go and to look at these
guys these features I was like this
particular feature these cells aren't
growing right I said so that's an
example of dysplasia right that's
dysplasia and then overall this lump
right is a new growth new growth it's a
neoplasia right and we you reserved it
in the medical field for me it's growing
on its own and how do we know it's new
because as you said it sticks around
yeah like the hyperplasia so so how'd
you know this wasn't around for like a
year
oh it probably was so I think it
actually came from an area here and the
thinking would be that you probably had
irritants or hyperplasia right it would
continue to grow cells divide so as to
buy too much and then one of them made a
mistake I see and so then it then
clicked on something where it would say
you know what from now on I'm not
listening to any clues a cup worker and
then all of its descendants were crazy -
that's right so then it would then have
a real mean streak yes and so then they
would grow from here so this is an area
where you can see I see that pattern in
my own family yeah exactly so then here
these are more normal glands but even
these yes that's dysplasia right right
so these are growing and they do not
have a good pattern of growth right
overall this lump right is a neoplasia I
see I see so when we say new it's kind
of newer than the other tissue oh yeah
we don't really need so much the new
or meaning that's new in the others as
much as its its own thing I see no new
kid on the block okay okay so so this is
the Nia place I see I see all right so
this one here is a polyp um it has
features of dysplasia right but we would
say we see no cancer
I see how would you know that and so um
and I write because it never co-found
real and this is there's a reason why
the boundary is important is that if you
look here these are all the surface
cells
um down here that these are the vessels
that go to the rest of the body right is
these are blood vessels right these ones
are called lymphatics and what
lymphatics are is they just take the
clear fluid right around there so so
these these right here these are the
emphatic stew clear fluid right and
there is a fluid can go back and forth
between blood vessels and the lymph
system yeah usually what happens is that
um blood comes in an artery like this
right goes on down to these little
vessels and then a little bit of the
clear parts of it right will kind of
leak out it like that the red blood
cells are too big yeah Kelsey and right
right so then the lymph is the clear
stuff that comes out and then this is
how it gets back to the rest your body
or through these lymphatic so you can
see you do not want neoplastic cells in
right because once in there neither they
can they can get to any part of the body
so any place and then guess what set up
shop New Kids on the Block they just do
with the Isthmus die I can't say the
word miss Costas metastases metastasis
so metastasis would be if it gets into
these things right I can get out of the
colon when you're in a variety so so
this is one where it is not cancer
and it has not invaded these areas where
it gets to the rest of the body
fascinating fascinating